excusez-moi un mot mais de ce que vous
faisiez bander des centaines de milliers
de jeunes gens et de l'homme quoi
c'était ça quand même au début votre
succès
plusieurs fois la censure s'est mêlée de
vos films dont jusqu'à votre dernier
film vous avez été le sexe symbole de
votre génération c'est à dire que vous
avez été l'actrice qui incarne la
sexualité la femme qui ose qui provoque
et qui comment dirait qui fait voler le
le carcan qui fait voler en éclat le
carcan de la morale donc là vous étiez
consciente de d'avoir ce rôle là dans le
cinéma dans la société française non
j'étais comme j'avais envie d'être je
savais pas que
je faisais sauter des carcans
je vous pose la question autrement votre
succès initial monsieur initial je dis
bien succès après vous devenez une très
bonne mais votre succès initial ça a été
ça a été votre joli frimousse qui était
qui était très jolie et puis surtout ce
corps que vous dans une société
complètement cadenassée complètement
fermée ce corps que vous exhibiez un
tout petit peu comment dire ce succès
ça vient de ce que je vais employer
excusez-moi un mot mais de ce que vous
faisiez bander des centaines de milliers
de jeunes gens et de l'homme quoi rester
ça quand même au début votre succès
moi je voyais je crois que ce que je
vois
le dire quand même
non dans fin de toute façon je suis
comme ça bon j'ai pas joué à être comme
ça je suis quelqu'un d'assez libre si
j'ai envie de me mettre en bikini je me
mets enfin pas maintenant parce que je
suis trop vieille mais à l'époque
j'avais envie de me mettre un bikini je
trouvais qu'il y avait aucune honte à se
mettre
je parle de des films et les films
c'était le reflet de ce que j'étais dans
ma vie
c'était évident
je ne sais pas voilà vous le savez pas
bon j'ai François nourricier avait fait
paraître un petit livre sur vous il y
avait des photographies il avait écrit
ça s'appelle bébé 60 donc il avait écrit
cet article en 1960 alors il est réédité
par le dilettante lire ce qu'il disait
il disait parle de votre beauté et de la
scandale que cette beauté provoquait la
beauté n'est pas honteuse la beauté a
des droits nous devons respect qui en
est une dignité d'avant la faute joueuse
et familière les gens qui une certaine
intensité de jeunesse fait ricaner me
dégoûte comme des peaux pas saines nues
elles se baignent nues elles se montrent
nue oui et comme tous les humains de 20
ans amis du soleil et de l'eau elle aura
rendu un peu ridicule les éternels
endimanchées de l'ordre et bien raison
ah oui bah c'est ce que je viens de vous
dire
1960 j'ai toujours été comme ça je n'ai
pas voulu être comme ça j'étais tel que
j'étais pas conscient de
des ravages que que vous provoquiez dans
la société française non et je suis
toujours pas consciente de rien du tout
j'ai jamais été consciente non non
Bernard écoutez
je le dis dans mon livre je n'ai jamais
été sûr de moi physiquement je me suis
toujours trouvé
pas aussi bien que ce que j'aurais voulu
être pour moi
bien sûr mais bien sûr
je suis peut-être complètement stupide
mais maintenant après le recul je me
rends compte que j'étais vraiment
quelqu'un d'assez joli mais au moment où
je vivais cette époque je ne le savais
pas
cette comment dire ce rire cette
fraîcheur cette sensualité communicative
cette cette santé joyeuse qu'on voit
d'ailleurs dans vos films qui est votre
votre marque c'est vrai qu'on la
retrouve dans les aventures au début de
les aventures des hommes que vous avez
aimé mais ça se termine toujours très
très mal on peut le dire en fait pas
toujours mais très souvent comment
expliquer on se dit que il était
probablement impossible pour une femme
comme vous de rester longtemps avec avec
des des hommes une star aussi
extraordinaire d'ailleurs vous le dites
c'est pas une question de star ou de
pasta je crois que
comme j'ai une enfance assez
élevé d'une façon assez sévère quand
j'ai commencé à vivre ma vie j'ai voulu
connaître des tas de choses voir tout un
tas de
d'interdit vivre une vie en brûlant la
chandelle parler debout et rattraper le
temps perdu probablement
et rattraper le temps d'après d'avant et
de pendant et j'ai éclaté dans une
espèce de folie d'existence qui fait que
je n'étais pas fidèle ça c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire que c'est difficile
d'être le compagnon le mari ou l'amant
d'une star rétrospectivement je plains
les hommes qui montaient mais qui ont
subi ces agressions stressantes
destructrices éloignées de ce que la vie
leur avait appris il fallait qu'ils
aient en eux une immense passion une
incommensurable patience pour surporter
une telle épreuve c'est vrai je le pense
profondément et je me dis que les
compagnons de mon existence à ce
moment-là fallait vraiment qu'ils aient
de la patience parce qu'on pouvait pas
sortir on pouvait rien faire on était
suivi par les paparazzis on pouvait
d'aider qui se passait quelque chose
c'est un scandale des photos un
scandales des c'était quand même
épouvantable de vivre avec moi c'était
très dur très très difficile
l'accepter quand même parce que quand
même beaucoup de gens qui l'acceptaient
bien sûr les pauvres
attendez nous nous parce que puisque
chez le j'ai quelques mois de différence
avec vous tout le monde tous les jeunes
ma générations voulaient être à la place
de trintignante Sami Fred Gilbert Bécaud
de charrier de
mais bon alors maintenant on se dit
voilà voilà quoi on a échappé quoi voilà
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que vous avez
aussi au fond de vous et vous le répéter
plusieurs vous avez horreur de la
solitude et vous avez besoin d'un appui
d'un réconfort ah oui j'ai besoin d'une
main d'une épaule
j'ai besoin de me voir dans les yeux
d'un homme qui m'aime et que j'aime j'ai
besoin d'une présence et je ne peux pas
vivre seul et ça c'est le le talon
d'Achille de mon existence
[Musique]